good afternoon welcome to the Heritage
Foundation and our Douglas and Sarah
Allison auditorium we of course welcome
those who join us on our heritage org
website on all of these occasions would
remind our guests here in the audience
if you'll be so kind to check cell
phones and other mobile devices to see
that they have been muted or turned off
as a courtesy it is always appreciated
for those also watching online you're
welcome to send questions or comments at
any time simply emailing speaker at
heritage org and we will of course post
the program on the Heritage homepage
following today's presentations as we
are all aware we of course are in the
middle of what might be called an
interesting political year as a
nonprofit organization heritage of
course will prefer to focus on policy
not necessarily politics but we know
some things will occur that go beyond
that but again just as the disclaimer
the Heritage Foundation as a 501 C
non-profit organization does not support
or oppose any particular candidate for
political office our program today is
hosted by the beacon of simon center for
principles and politics its sponsors
lectures organizes seminars and crafts
publications with the goal of teaching
those who shape opinion about the
foundations of Liberty the center
focuses on the principles of America
political tradition the fundamentals of
economic freedom and the basics of
conservative thought and public policy
leading our discussion today is Arthur
Milic assistant director of the beacon
assignment center for principles and
politics please welcome him Arthur
Heritage Foundation
since 9/11 we faced 89 Islamist plots
against the United States homeland 11 of
which were successful why part of it is
because we're in the habit of constantly
under estimating our enemies and this
comes out in subtle ways for example
each time a terrorist attack occurs the
press and the administration are quick
to call them tragedies well these are
without doubt Sat occasions this
formulation points to a problem with our
own psychology tragedy means fate as in
unavoidable fate like Oedipus belief
that we suffer tragedies because of
faith disarms us spiritually it says we
should not take action because
mysterious forces stronger than us
ultimately dictate our circumstances
another favorite term attributed to our
enemies is that they evolved as in Isis
has evolved the air here is similar our
enemies - as it turns out are guided by
mysterious fate called evolution in
other words their actions are not
attributed to thoughtfulness motive and
design misunderstanding our enemies and
thereby avoiding the necessity of war
culminates in the astonishing words of
attorney general Loretta Lynch how
should we fight terrorism well with
compassion unity and love she recently
said this is the form of public
education taken by many in the press and
this administration over the years
general Flynn and Michael Dean's
excellent book the field of fight is
also engaged in public education but it
strikes the opposite tone it shows how
formidable our enemies are it shows
their conscious ambitions and plans but
it also shows how American ingenuity and
character are superior
it shows how our many advantages over
the long haul will prove stronger but
victory begins in acknowledging the
nature of the enemies we face and
accepting the fact that we are indeed at
war over 33 years general Flynn has
toured the highest positions and
military intelligence most recently he
was director of the
a Defense Intelligence Agency prior to
that he served for five years in Iraq
and Afghanistan as director of
intelligence for Joint Special
Operations Command where he was credited
with completely changing and then
revolutionizing how intelligence
supports operations general Flynn also
served as senior intelligence advisor to
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff astonishingly he's also the
recipient of four Bronze Stars dr.
Michael Dean is a historian and an
internationally renowned scholar of
terrorism Islam Iraq he's the author of
35 books he's currently the freedom
scholar in the foundation of defense of
democracies and prior to that he served
in a variety of roles as consultant in
nationals in the National Security
Council in the State Department Defense
Department was a special adviser to the
Secretary of State I'll now turn to the
authors we'll begin with You general
Flynn each will speak for about 10
minutes or so and then we'll turn it
over to questions great great Thank You
Arthur when you're getting ready to
write a book find somebody who wrote 35
of them and and partner up with them I
really am honored to be here and it's a
real honor to be up here with Mike Lee
Dean who is not only the co-author of
this great book is this unbelievable
message that it has in it for our
country but he's also a great friend and
and I see some other friends out in the
audience here today we we as a nation
must demonstrate willingness resolve and
determination to ensure the survival of
our country
I mean is it at risk today I don't know
is it at risk over the next four years
it gets closer to being a higher risk
than it does sitting here today is it at
risk to survive by the middle of this
next by the middle of this century or by
the end of this century
absolutely absolutely all you have to do
is study world history or study our own
history in this experiment that we are a
part of called the United States of
America so in in the book now we talk
about solutions we talk about alliances
we talk about all of these things that
we are facing and I
think it captured it's a very captured
very well I believe in very simple
language that's very practical so I
think that the the book speaks for
itself and and and I hope that you take
the opportunity to go out and and get a
copy of it and read it and then talk
about it because it is a very very
powerful and almost urgent message
now back back to where we are and what
we're doing today this is this is
probably as I have gone back and looked
certainly over the last year how
important this particular election is
this is not one that the American voter
can sit out okay so we are in a in a
historic era in our country and our
country's going through some big shifts
and I think that people need to
understand where our country is that
when we talk about warfare when I talk
about warfare that that was my adult
life was studying it and so one of the
things that we all that we all are
trained on are different you know
individuals who have written about
warfare over the history of warfare you
know people like Sun Tzu and Clausewitz
and all these others write really really
important and you know one of the
tenants of of Sun tzuf both for both for
military thinking and also even in the
business world is you have to know your
competitor or know your enemy right know
your enemy know your enemy know your
enemy
I mean that has been ingrained in me and
I'll tell you lots of us that have that
have served this country it doesn't make
any difference whether you're an
intelligence officer or not you must
know your enemy now as I sit up here
today and I do
I dabble in the business world know your
competitor know your competitor it's the
same concept but know your enemy if you
don't know your enemy then you cannot
figure out a way to defeat them period I
mean it's that simple and so we have in
this book have described that notion
this idea about clearly defining this
idea this ideology this very cancerous
barbaric vicious cunning savvy
ideology that we call radical Islam and
the second big part of the book is
really describing a strategy to win
because we we can never think that our
enemies are ten feet tall I think during
during the era of communism post-world
War two for for the better part of 40
years we we you know we would look at
these at our enemies as though they were
10 feet tall no enemies 10 feet tall all
enemies are beatable the Nazis we beat
had Adolphe Hitler 175 years ago let's
say I mean not that long ago not that
long ago had he won we'd all be praying
at the altar of Nazism so thank God for
the United States of America thank God
we did what we did and we called out
these isms last century Nazism fascism
imperialism and communism yet today
we're not allowed to necessarily do that
we have this we have this difficulty
because we are a nation built on
certainly built on laws and I like to
think that the rule of law is probably
the biggest strategic advantage that we
have we're also a nation built on a set
of freedoms and one of those freedoms is
our freedom of religion and so we have
to be very conscious of a very
determined enemy this is a very
determined enemy that is is masking
itself behind it's this ideology and I
personally my personal belief of this
ideology is this is a political ideology
based on Islam it's a political ideology
and and it masks itself particularly in
our country behind this religion so a
very strong views in the in the and I'm
going to stop here and just turn it over
to Michael the beauty of writing a book
with Michael a Dean is it's like you
know we're growing up in a family of
nine in my house sitting around a little
you know picnic table that was our
dining room table arguing about politics
with my mother you know and debating
these kinds of issues and so the last
this past year and even before that as
we were debating this issue and and
prior to deciding to
this book you know arguing about it and
he's arguing we have different views
about different things and and he said
you know what you ought to write that
down you ought to put it down and and
say it you know call it out and so we
decided to do that and the the
fascinating sort of timing is everything
it's interesting when we were in New
York with the publisher st. Martin's and
Macmillan we we picked yesterday the
12th of July a year ago not knowing all
this other stuff that's going on in the
media today we picked the 12th because
we wanted this message to get out in
front of whoever was going to be the
next president prior to the conventions
the Republican and then the Democratic
convention because I want people
personally and I know Michael believe
this as well we want people to read this
message that's in this book it's super
powerful it's practical and it and it
tells a story about what we are facing
as a nation
most Americans can't figure out what
they're gonna do for Saturday night okay
we lack strategic thinking in this
country we lack it our national security
system and staff in the decision-making
process around the highest office in the
land is broken people everybody knows
that you know those of us that have
dabbled in it we know it today we
definitely know it today so I'll stop
there and and say again to heritage
thank you very much for having us here
today appreciate the the opportunity and
the time and I'll turn it over to my
good friend Michael a Dean Thank You
general so you can't imagine what high
price it is to be compared to mama Flynn
that's a but but for me the most fun
part of the book was a section which I
always thought of this growing up Flynn
because general Flynn grew up in the
house he was one of nine siblings in a
one-bathroom house and they all had to
be out of the door at the same time in
the morning and if you want to know how
military discipline develops that's
where it starts because if you can
manage that it came from River and she's
a woman who was on her way through
college got pregnant dropped out of the
university raised nine children went
back to the University counter degree
got a law degree I mean an amazing
amazing woman that's where it comes from
our daughter actually worked for general
Flynn at a certain point in Iraq and
Afghanistan and in the middle of the
book I called her up one day and I said
does he ever sleep and she said you were
only now beginning to understand what
it's like he's an extremely dynamic hard
thinking clear thinking man and I hope
that the book captures that of the of
the various things that the that field
of fight addresses the two main concepts
that I hope you'll go away with today
are number one we are in a global war
and our enemies are both radical Muslims
which everybody knows about by now but
hardly anybody talks about accurately
and radical secularists it's an alliance
it's not just one or the other
vitomir Putin is not a Muslim the the
dictator of North Korea is not a Muslim
but they're in cahoots and they work
together and they share a common
objective which is our destroy
and our domination so that's what we're
at the Alliance that we face runs from
Pyongyang to Havana to Caracas through
Teheran and Baghdad and so forth
it's a huge alliance it's very daunting
and as somebody once said about people
like this they may be grazing but
they're not stupid and they are
preparing for this war and they're
waging this war Iran has been waging war
against us since 1979 and they're still
at it and it's very hard to discuss
seriously the war that Iran has waged
against us because we're all wrapped up
in an epiphenomenon okay that's one
thing number two if we're gonna win this
war we have to go after the doctrines
that they preach and we have to expose
them as false and hollow and losing and
at a certain point we'd take off after
Muslim culture and say look let's face
it everybody knows above all themselves
everybody knows that this is a failed
civilization my favorite factoid in the
modern world is translations of books
into Arabic and therefore the access
that Arabic speakers have to the
literature of the world to philosophy
science culture so forth and the factoid
is this I find it still incredible every
time I Sam there were more books
translated into Spanish last year than
have been translated into Arabic in the
last thousand years right one year into
Spanish more than a thousand years a
millennium of Arabic so they don't know
and if you read the popular press in the
Middle East you will find all these
incredible things about why things
happen and what you have to do and so
forth
I mean it's a anybody wants to prop
tenant and have fun talking about a
failed state or a failed civilization
boy that's where you start I mean just
it's a bottomless pit of the anecdotes
and horror stories and so forth people
in that part of the world as I said may
be crazy but they're not stupid and they
know it they know it's a failure that is
paradoxically one reason why so many of
them are following things like al-qaeda
and Isis and this round and so forth
because these people come to them and
say the reason why we failed is because
we're not doing it right
and we have to go back to basic
doctrines and live the way Mohammed
lived and follow the models that
Mohammed light down and then we'll win
and in fact in the early days of
al-qaeda following 9/11 and so forth you
would you would hear bin Laden saying
all the time we win because Allah has
blessed our efforts we have divine
support we are doing it right and a few
people will follow us and do it right we
will win - so my question is and we need
to be asking them this openly every
single time that we have challenged them
on the battlefield we have won without
exception we beat them in Iraq we beat
them in Afghanistan and then we ran away
well what every time we beat them our
leaders should have stood up and said
well what's that all about
you know here you told us that you were
you had divine blessing what happened
did a lot change sides that he decide to
support us in Iraq and Afghanistan and
so forth what's going on here I mean you
have to go right for the heart of the
doctrine what they believe what they
preach how they recruit what's going on
because that's a big part of their
dynamism and it's a central core of the
yeah of the movements and the
Alliance that we face and the same
applies to the secular tyrants nobody in
the world wants to be the new North
Korea plan where Putin is not a global
hero or inspiration I mean he may be
feared
he may be admired in some quarters but
nobody wants them and people outside
Russia don't want to live the way the
residents living Heldman most Russians
know that they would be better off if
they were free to live the way they
chose so it's a world made for America
this book lays out the various steps
that we have to take how to do it who
should do it and so forth and it's been
a great privilege and and a great
pleasure to work with general Flynn I
hope you enjoy field fight and I hope
y'all have questions for us thank you
Thanks if I may I'll take the first
question and then we'll turn to the
audience this is for both authors can
you be specific what exact weaknesses do
they see in US and how do they exploit
them is the weakness the influence of
public opinion and therefore an
exploitation of the press is it over
investment in certain technologies that
they come back more cheaply what is the
exact weakness that they have identified
that they're pursuing yeah let me this
house jump on that Michael give you a
second to think about it because you
probably be a lot more thoughtful I
would say we have what we're challenged
these days and and I and I've actually
written about this what we have
forgotten how to win wars and I wrote an
article on it's about three months ago
you know America has forgotten how to
win its wars and and there is a real
weakness in our own ability to go in and
use our you know from a pure military
perspective and go in and just truly
crush our enemies and win and what we do
it's it's
what we're seeing right now I mean two
years ago we had a hundred and seventy
five soldiers in Iraq okay so over the
last two years we've been creeping up
adding more and more people to the
battlefield of Iraq and today we're
probably if you really counted the
numbers were probably upwards of about
six thousand people in Iraq so what what
is it that's happening that we can't
understand that it's it actually it
takes a different path to actually win
and so I think that our our weaknesses
understanding that when we go to war you
go to war to win you don't go to war to
you know protect Pizza Hut or Burger
King or some of the things some of the
nonsense that I've seen on upon our
battlefields and this goes back this
goes way back this goes back to you can
even see this for anybody that served in
Vietnam that might be in this room we
have got to decide that when we go to
war and we talked a little bit about
this I've talked about this when my
father served in World War two
he served in both World War two in Korea
you know he was a corporal in World War
two he wasn't told you know go to Europe
for four months or six months and then
you can come back and you know and
there'll be a plenty of big bases there
for you to serve on and don't worry
about it you know no my father was told
you're gonna go and in his case the
European campaign you're gonna go to war
and you're not coming home until we've
won and we've told this to our
leadership so I'm sitting here today and
as I can tell you as a colonel in the
early parts of this war we told this to
our leadership that look if you told us
to go and fight these guys and you're
not coming home until you've won we
would have fought we would have had a
totally different strategy because
believe me none of us wants to stay in
those godforsaken places nobody no
American wants to why would you give up
the beauty that we have in this all in
this country but when people are are
screaming for freedom and someone is
attacking our way of life but our so our
strategic thinking about how we go to
war and fight wars has changed
fundamentally and that's a big weakness
that
they know they study us this is not a
bunch of guys who I facetiously have
said are in shower shoes and bathrobes
because twice twice they were beating us
on the battlefield the most modern
military formed on the battlefield 2006
in Iraq in 2009 in Afghanistan and I'm
sitting here today telling you that they
have the strategic initiative they have
the global strategic initiative and I
don't care if they lose Fallujah I don't
care if they lose Raqqa I mean look at
what they have been able to do globally
globally there's a global footprint we
we have to recognize that the the
strategy that they have assumed is a
global strategy and the strategy that we
have assumed and taken on is a very
narrow tactical strategy we have to be
much more strategic and they understand
that weakness in our system and they
fully fully exploit it Michael would you
like this how well the short answer is
what do they see in us that encourages
them so much is what general Flint says
we lack the will to win they see a
failure of will and they're not afraid
of us they think they can do anything
they want to and we will not unleash a
devastating response they're not afraid
then they expect to win we have all the
watches they have all the time different
than that but it's it's a it's not
watch's in time it's resolved in
willingness and determination ok that's
what it is big decision making survival
of this country when you go back and you
look at the founding fathers and all the
experiments that we had thank God for
people like Abraham Lincoln okay I mean
one vote could have could have split
this country in half but the
determination the willingness and the
resolve and I use those words because
they're they're very precise in what we
need and I will take as I was asked this
the other day you know while the
American public are tired the American
public will be tired if they lose
because they'll be slaves
okay like I said like I said about
Hitler had Hitler won this world would
be totally different we wouldn't be we
would be challenged to have a forum like
this people probably unlikely that we
would have one so you know the
willingness the determination and the
resolve to win is super super important
in any endeavor but particularly in
warfare particularly in warfare yeah
okay thank you gentleman right here Oh
once I can wait for the microphone
please general Sagar and jetty with the
Daily Caller News foundation given some
previous statements you've made in the
past supporting the US Russia
cooperation what do you think of the
Obama administration's deal with Putin
to cooperate on targets inside Syria
yeah I would just offer in terms of how
we deal with Russia and I've told Russia
this - they need to get Iran the heck
out of the for proxy wars that they are
in right now so we can settle this
situation down now we lost that
opportunity we missed an opportunity to
I think through through essentially I
think weak diplomacy but we could have
been a lot tougher to have made that you
know demand know that there has to be
and I like this word there has to be
reciprocity in the way we deal with
others around the world
okay they want something from us we need
something back and what we need is we
need to settle this situation down in
the Middle East and one of the things
that Michael and I talk about in this
book is we talk about this idea about a
21st century alliance and we talk about
some of the leaders that are in the in
the Muslim world and so so you know back
to your question about Russia Russia has
to understand and they know this they
know this that they have as big a
problem with this element that we
described in this book as we do in fact
it's actually sort of the wolf's closest
to the sled and right now they're there
that you know they're there on the sled
and they're it's really close to them
Dagestan Chechnya the other Central
Asian republics and some of the problems
that they're having there so this funny
alliance between Russia and Iran
we have to understand why we have to
understand why I mean when people go
well why should we deal with Russia hey
we just dealt with Russia on a Iranian
nuclear deal why and I asked why that
right so so what I would tell you is
that we have to be we have to be tough
we have to be demanding we have to be
very precise and we have to acknowledge
that there are times in our own history
and and certainly going forward where we
have to pick and choose certain things
that we are going to do okay with with
you know others around the world but it
comes from acknowledging our own selfish
self interests as an American and that's
that's really important because guess
what Russia has a national security
strategy you ought to read it you can
find elements of it online and it
doesn't have anything to do with us
other than other than you know anti-west
anti-us go look at the go look at the
partnership that china and russia just
crafted just signed okay Shanghai
Cooperation Organization go look at it
it's fascinating
so anti-west so anti Americans military
and economic so we're nobody's even
talking about that because of all the
other problems that were you know again
that we're facing right here right now
in our own country and of course a big
national election where there's going to
be a big decision so you know there's a
lot there to my answer you know to your
great question but very important that
we understand what is it but what is in
the best interest of our country Thanks
okay gentlemen on the front
my name is Michael Krause I'm chairman
of secure chain I'm taken by your your
comment about win totally general
Fleming and Michael I'm also a historian
Second World War
my father fought in the Second World War
on the Russian front I'm an immigrant
here when my father saw what happened to
his country he said we're getting out of
here we're going to America and we'll
win I'm taken by your comment I call
about Vietnam my first war a policy of
gradualism does not win the gradual
application of power does not win and it
seems to me for some time we have tried
to apply power gradually and we've only
looked at it in the military sense
instead of the psychological ideological
political and financial economic sense
we are challenged and we must win if
this country is going to be what it is
what are your thoughts about gradualism
as an application of policy well there's
lots of different ways to win but but
you have to have the will to win when
you start it off so there may be
circumstances in which gradualism works
and other circumstances in which doesn't
work depends who the enemy is what
drives me crazy is the unwillingness of
a lot of people to look at what
superpower status entails and what kind
of world we want to live in we want to
live it seems to me in the world in
which people don't want to mess with us
because if they mess with us
they're gonna be destroyed that's what
superpower
means right it's not like you know
attacking your neighbor next door it's
you know you mess with the United States
you you're not going to survive for
right now nobody in the world has that
conviction nobody believes that they
think they'll have time they'll be
willing to talk we're not going to
invade them or if we do it won't last
very long and will go away and so forth
and that's a very very dangerous world
and it's all part of a huge problem that
we face nationally which is ignorance of
history and above all ignorance of
military history the number of
universities in this country that teach
serious military history aside from some
pockets in the south that do civil war
out of nostalgia or patriotism or or
whatever you can count on one hand they
don't exist nobody knows and Americans
one of my favorite Churchill lines is
that America goes to war to learn
geography because because without war we
didn't know anything about geography so
we have a huge educational failure and
that place into it but I think by a
larger right and what we want our
potential enemies to know with certainty
is that they come after us they will not
survive ok gentlemen over here thank you
Ryan Braun with CNN general you
mentioned earlier that the National
Security Council had kind of had a role
in kind of the policy failures in
countering Isis could you talk a little
bit about I know on Capitol Hill they're
talking about potentially reforming it
and making it congressionally confirmed
if they get too big can you talk a
little bit about the role of the NSC and
what role should it play in combating
Isis and other national security policy
yeah
so the National Security Council
consists of the President the Vice
President the Secretary of State and
Secretary of Defense the national
security staff that surrounds the
National Council is bloated and it's and
I love I love young people I love to
take you know good care and counsel and
and mentor and and help grow young
people but the National staff right now
is so young and inexperienced and it's
very clear and it's too big it's just
flat too big with with that size of an
organization that sits around the
decision making body called the National
Security Council of the you know that
right around the president when it's so
big and it it lacks an agility everybody
has their own little you know thing that
they want to get into the President or
the Vice President or the Secretary of
State or the Secretary of Defense and
certainly into the president you know we
end up piecemealing ourselves and so I
think that there in fact there's some
really good work that was just recently
done by if it's okay to mention by the
Atlantic Council and I think that it's
it's really good work and it's so true
it's
too big it's too it's too young and
inexperienced and what we need to do is
we need to really neck that down to the
to a place where where we can have the
agility the flexibility the
responsiveness you know the the the
types of strategic thinking and and and
advising that a president needs to be
able to make decisions are our quote
unquote the interagency process I don't
know how many time sick of that word the
or phrase the interagency process I'm
sick of it doesn't work doesn't work so
it's going to we're going to take it
into the interagency process god help us
okay okay on the battlefield on the
battlefield when we said yeah it's in
the interagency process I would tell
people go act don't you go do what you
what you need to do and I'll you know
you know I'll provide the cut the top
cover of whatever it is that you're
going to do because we cannot we cannot
operate in a world that's moving at the
speed of light today with the national
security staff structure that we have
around what Michael Levine just
described as the most powerful country
on the planet and and we just can't have
it because we have to have an agility in
our in our strategic decision-making and
that and that is a real problem today
one of the things that I'm gonna put a
shout out to an organization a
university that that I am aligned with
or a part of is Institute of world
politics it's one of the only places
like Michael talking about with history
it's one of the only places that I'm
aware that really teaches you know
really deeply teaches statecraft what a
statecraft mean you know instead I got
an international relations degree what
you study you know what you study I got
one of those you know I know what I
study I mean but did you really deeply
study statecraft because it gets to your
a great question this is more this is
more than just about a military thing
okay as a military guy this is more than
just about military power this is about
all elements of power how but how do you
understand that how do you apply that
how do you you know you
you you know mr. or mrs. president do
you understand all of that and I think
that that's a real important part of of
what we need to do because we're going
where we are going to need we must must
must must reform the national security
structure around the executive branch of
government okay
gentleman in the glasses you didn't
shout that's okay
oh there you go well good afternoon and
thank you general Flynn and Michael for
coming here today and thank you author
for heritage for hosting this now ah
general you mentioned earlier that in
the 20th century we wiped out all the
isms communism Nazism fascism life
completely but but we did a damn good
job we did we did and Samuel Huntington
wrote about that in the clash of
civilizations in 1993 and he said the
next war would be a war based on culture
and I think that's what we're seeing
here now and you've both talked about
winning so what does winning mean to you
what does it look like do we have to
actually wipe out the Islamic culture do
do we have to modify it so that it is
more in line with world norms or do we
just put them at rest for a while as
we've done for the last thirteen hundred
years and wait for them to resurrect
themselves again I'll give you a short
answer and and turn over to Michael to
offer his thoughts we should not be
afraid or we should not fear what our
country was built on you know a set of
judeo-christian principles now we do
weaves like this sense of fear in our
country that because of you know hey
well you know we okay I mean I you know
there are there are cultures around the
world that I and this is not a this is
not a racist issue I could care less if
somebody's purple polka-dotted you know
this is about it internationally
acceptable standards of behavior and
what I want is I want a standard of
behavior that is internationally
accepted and in some sort of in our
country you know follow our
our laws follow our rules
internationally follow the sort of what
is it what is an international
acceptance of behavior and not and not
you know treat women the way that we see
some women treated to treat children
boys and girls the way that they are
treated I mean so so yeah either are
there societies are there cultures that
have a higher acceptance of of behavior
and and actions and attitudes absolutely
I believe ours does absolutely believe
ours does so that's that's sort of where
I'm at on this I mean this is something
where you know it's like President
al-sisi says and he we talked about him
in this book it's fascinating and I you
know I'm a I'm a fan of what he did
which was to take on his religion you
know and eat a paraphrase of it but he
essentially says should we expect 1.2
billion Muslims to kill the other 7
billion people on the planet he's asking
he's asking his culture he's asking his
world that question then he said and
basically says no we can't have that and
he calls for a revolution or a
reformation and I think that that was so
intellectually courageous for a guy
who's fighting he has a knife fight
going on in his country against an
organization called the Muslim
Brotherhood and you look at their
Charter and what they say about us it's
unacceptable it's unacceptable do you
want to add something Michael
ok ok this other gentleman in the
glasses probably right here thank you my
name is Darren BT and I'm a Heidegger
scholar I have a question for dr.
Michael la Dean and this maybe is a more
pointed way to ask the previous question
which was excellent and that's to do
with what does winning mean because in
your in your talk you made a point to
mention both
radical islamists and secular dictators
which indicates to me that winning would
involve having neither such group in
charge in the Middle East and so with
that in mind I would ask what is winning
in terms of the best realistic outcome
in the Middle East is it full women's
rights in Afghanistan or is it
minimizing the likelihood and potential
of a homeland attack in the United
States very different objectives so in
light of this and in light of your
expertise in Iran when we saw secular
dictator Islamic extremists and
so-called moderates an analogous
situation in Syria except unlike the
Shah Assad is not our friend so what
lessons can we learn from that in light
of this overriding question of the best
realistic outcome in in these countries
thank you love to answer it but you have
to tell me what a high Newkirk scholar
is where is there a high degree you in
town that I'm not aware of where does
that come from one man in it it's so
very small okay yes I'll take I'll take
freedom for women in Afghanistan I'm one
town I want I want freedom across the
board and the answer there is no short
answer to your question because
circumstances vary so much I would
however if I were you be very careful
about alleging that Syria is not that
Assad is not as great a friend of ours
as the Shah was or at least we don't
think about him this way they were alive
American leaders we are well on our way
right now to an embrace of Assad and
then what we say and then you will say
hey you already tried this
and it didn't work out and I thought
it's a monster look what he's done to
his own people look at half the
population of Syrians run away hundreds
of thousands of Syrians killed by him
and yet we're about to embrace him that
won't work
and so I suppose in that regard I'm
still unreconstructed American
revolutionary witches I want freedom I
want free societies and I think that
given access to facts information and
the world is working in that direction
people in the Middle East who a
generation ago only knew what their
neighborhood Imam had to say on any
given subject now we're online and they
have access to all kinds of information
that they never knew about before and
their local neighborhood Imam is trying
to shut that down because they know how
dangerous it is to them we want a free
world that's what America stands for so
that includes women who don't want to
wear burqas not wearing burkas women who
want to go to the universities and go to
the universities if it ran were a free
country it would be probably the highest
female the educational level anywhere in
that part of the world
Helen probably is already there were
more women in America in Iranian
universities than there were our men
drives the regime crazy because they
insist in keeping with their doctrines
that women are inferior it it's a failed
civilization we need to give them that
push and we need to address the citizens
of all those countries and say you don't
have to take this
we'll help you get rid of this well
we'll help you become free constitution
of Afghanistan isn't half bad every year
Stanford Law School sends a handful of
young attorneys to be over and attorneys
over to
Afghanistan to walk young judges and
lawyers through the contents of the
Constitution of Afghanistan to explain
to them what their options are that's
what we want we want that kind of world
in which the people over there have
access to this thing and I have I have
no doubt which way they will what
they're going to choose if we behave in
the way that general fund is advocating
with the will to win and the confidence
and our own values and so forth one of
the reason why we're so unpopular right
now there's different kinds of
anti-americanism one of the most lethal
is people who hit America because they
think America is not up to it because
we're not there those are the people who
are in the streets of Teheran with big
signs saying where are you
we're not there we have to be there and
there are lots of different ways of
being there yeah let me just say you
know talk about this business about you
know a failed system you know what
another area that we we need to be seen
as and and I think in some cases taking
some action leaders you know global
leadership from a from a global
leadership perspective is in how do you
change an economic system that's built
upon one one element and and how do you
talk about education
okay there's a reason why a lot of you
know there's a lot of Muslims that's
that send children to schools in London
Paris New York Boston Washington DC you
know and so when they send them what
when they go back what is it that
they're doing you know are they are they
looking to see something different and
that and so the answer that question is
yes they are so I know this I've talked
to many of these people that are in a
position that they they see that they
must change and they're trying they are
trying so it's not just a you know we're
going to drop a bunch of bombs and it's
all over that we've already proven
that doesn't work that that narrow
strategy doesn't work there has to be
other elements there has to be other
elements of power which which goes back
to your question again Michael the the
this idea of helping people understand
that new economic systems can be created
I mean we're in the middle of one right
now
that's called it you know there's this
information IT revolution that's going
on globally how can others take
advantage of that so there's there's
other ways that we must be imaginative
but at the bot and of the day it's about
freedom it's about freedom and I'm a big
big advocate on how people treat women
because I think that that's a that's a
big deal it's a big deal that's it's in
some cases it's more than half the
population so we're we are not tapping
into the potential of that segment of
the population now we do we do a pretty
good job of that
I think we do a great job of that but
not the rest of the world doesn't do
that or big parts of the world doesn't
doesn't do that and it's and it actually
impacts the health of that society so
the health of that society is sick
because that's because they don't tap
into that that intellect that
intellectual capital that they have to
you know to and to be able to to thrive
in a way that they could thrive
totally different that's what is going
to have to happen as we go forward
because as Michael Levine highlighted
what we are connected the people that
had no voice in the past or that were
voiceless in the past they now have a
voice and they have it through you know
the basically the information
technologies that exist and it's going
that is going to improve so that type of
improvement in our in our societies to
be able to communicate its these
believing these countries you they try
to shut down Facebook they shut try to
shut down Twitter they you know if you
have a satellite dish antenna on your on
your roof in the past it was taken off I
mean all these kinds of things
so that that will change that's going to
change and and there is going to be a
market for the voices of the world that
have been voiceless in the past and we
need to kind of listen to what they're
saying and we need to be prepared to
help them in different ways okay we have
time for one more question unfortunately
the lady in the somewhat blue shirt
thank you so much
Thank You general Thank You mr. Lee Dean
for speaking today my name is dr. Laura
Corr and I'm radicalization team lead
and visiting fellow at the American
leadership and policy foundation you
identified radical Islam as a cancer in
other countries have identified this
cancer and have been very aggressive in
their avenues programs and policies
where do you see the United States
moving forward in combating this cancer
effectively whether it's your education
think tanks experts where do you
specifically see the United States
making more strides and combating this
cancer and my second question is would
you both be so kind as to sign my book
thank you so much yeah signing books is
one of the nicest things that can happen
to any author so yeah yeah so yes and
the answer to what what do we advocate
how do we challenge radical Islam yes to
all those things you suggested yes
education
yes public statements but it has to
begin with leadership it has to begin I
was lucky enough to serve in the Reagan
administration when we were fighting
global communism all right what happened
everybody's forgotten every time the
Secretary of State went to an
international meeting and there was some
communist leader there he would show up
with the list of political prisoners he
would denounce their system he would say
at least these people stop this form of
behavior and so forth our leaders have
to stand up and say we're being attacked
by
radical Islam it's crazy it's wrong and
it's failed and he has to send in the
Secretary of State has to say in the
Secretary of Defense s to say it our
leaders have to say in all the time
instead we have now two consecutive
administrations where you couldn't say
radical Islam you couldn't use the
phrase can talk about it right and you
know and they see that and they know
that and they conclude we're afraid of
them therefore they're winning and so it
goes on you know yeah would you like to
add something yeah I mean the only thing
I would add to what Michaels talking
about I mean we just have to be we have
to be very very realistic and like I
said at the beginning you have to
understand the enemy that you are facing
you have to be able to clearly clearly
clearly define that enemy because until
it because until you do you can't lay
out you know all of the elements of what
it is that you're facing if it was just
countering violent extremists I mean
I've been called an extremist you know I
mean so I mean it this is this is very
precise and once we once we are able to
do that then it does get back to the
leadership and how we how our most
senior leader and then those that in
that National Security Council structure
how they deal with with the
relationships around the world and what
demands we put on them I you know
remember I use that word reciprocity
okay if if I was to use it with any
country I use it with China the
reciprocity is something that we must
consider when we deal with people around
the world I mean if we have Americans
that are held against their will in a
country and we're gonna go deal with
that country we're gonna go give that
country something why and until they say
until I say give me that America back
maybe then off you know give me that
America back and then
maybe I'll think about dealing with you
okay otherwise we're gonna take the
following actions
that's tough diplomacy there's a
difference between diplomacy and tough
diplomacy and smart diplomacy so I think
that it's something that we we're going
to have to deal with as we go forward in
what has already been described by many
people as one of the most complex times
in our history so with that I just want
to say thanks to heritage this is great
I hope you all got something out of it
now thank you so much for being here and
really on behalf of my great friend Mike
Levine I just want to say thanks and by
the book it's a great message yep thank
you
[Applause]